All righty. So as we know, patients with classic Hodgkin lymphoma that relapse after autologous
stem cell transplant have historically poor outcomes, and recurrence often occurs at the
site of disease relapse prior to transplant. So as a result, clinicians may utilize peritransplant
radiation to involve sites, sites of bulky disease, and to areas with less than CR prior
to transplant. And what we see in retrospective studies is that this approach does improve local
disease control, but the evidence supporting a PFS and OS benefit is less well-defined.
And then importantly, the role of peritransplant radiation in the era of novel immunotherapy is
unclear. So to better inform our use of peritransplant radiation, we conducted a
multi-center retrospective study, and specifically we collaborated with five U.S. academic institutions
to create a study that showed that peritransplant radiation can be used to improve local disease
control. And we identified patients treated with transplant from 2010, that should say 2023,
and we defined peritransplant radiation as radiation administered within three months
of transplant before or after. And we compared the post-transplant PFS and OS between the two
groups, and also looked at treatment trends over the years. So in total, we identified just under
30,000 patients with classic Hodgkin lymphoma. And we identified patients treated with transplant
over the years. So in total, we identified just under 1,300 patients. 1,008 did not receive
peritransplant radiation, and 284 did. And here I'm highlighting the baseline variables that were
significantly associated with receipt of peritransplant radiation. And those included
early-stage disease at relapse, bulky disease at relapse, which we defined as greater than five
centimeters, primary refractory disease, more than one line of salvage before transplant,
and then less than CR prior to transplant. And then conversely on this,
I'm just showing the baseline variables that were significantly associated with no receipt
of peritransplant radiation. And this included extra nodal disease at relapse,
B symptoms at relapse, radiation at initial diagnosis, checkpoint inhibitor in combination
with anything at any point during salvage, and BV maintenance. As I said, we also looked at
treatment trends, and we defined treatment eras as pre-BV approval, post-BV approval,
BV approval, and post-checkpoint inhibitor approval. And what you can see here is between
the pre-BV and post-BV approval, there was really no difference in the utilization of
peritransplant radiation. But after the approval of checkpoint inhibitors in 2016,
in the relapse refractory setting, you can see that the utilization of peritransplant radiation
halved from 31% to 15%. In our univariable analysis, we can see that the patients that
did receive peritransplant radiation had a higher rate of peritransplant radiation than
those who did not receive peritransplant radiation. So those shown in green had superior PFS and OS
compared to those who did not, shown in blue. And this association between radiation and PFS and OS
was significant, shown by these hazard ratios at the bottom.
And then after controlling for several clinically relevant variables in our multivariable analysis,
we saw that this relationship between PFS and peritransplant radiation held true. And
then after controlling for several clinically relevant variables in our multivariable analysis,
however, this association between peritransplant radiation and overall survival was lost,
and so we can see that in the bottom row of this box.
We also did an interaction effect analysis, taking into consideration variables that may
be considered when choosing peritransplant radiation. So this included bulky disease relapse,
the salvage regimen, and less than CR prior to transplant. And what we saw was that there was
no significant interaction between peritransplant radiation and these variables with PFS,
which is in that first column, and OS, which is in that second column.
Nevertheless, we were still interested in whether or not there was some difference in the effect
that peritransplant radiation had based on the salvage regimen. And so we did an additional sub
group experiment. And we did an additional sub group experiment. And we did an additional sub
exploratory analysis looking at PFS based on the salvage regimen. And what you can clearly see
here is that the patients who only got chemo in salvage, so that's the curve on the far left,
seemed to benefit the most from peritransplant radiation. And this is in comparison to the
patients who got BV in combination with chemotherapy, plus or minus, as well as the
patients who got checkpoint radiation, plus or minus, as well as the patients who got checkpoint
inhibitor at any time point in salvage, which is shown on the far right.
Okay. I'm going quicker than I thought. So in conclusion, I think the big takeaways from this
is that we were able to show that there was a significant association between peritransplant
radiation and PFS. And although we did show an association with overall survival in our
univariate analysis, this was lost in multivariate analysis. And then there was no significant
interaction between peritransplant radiation and bulky disease salvage regimen and pre-transplant
response with PFS and OS. And we saw decreased utilization of peritransplant radiation in the
patients receiving checkpoint inhibitors. And those patients seem to derive the least amount
of benefit from peritransplant radiation. So some prospective validation is warranted.